democrats on the house judiciary
committee are launching an
investigation to find out how the trump
administration's justice department
used secret court orders to obtain
digital records of journalists
and democratic lawmakers from apple
present from apple's president
biden's attorney general merrick garland
has ordered an independent investigation
into what happened
jeff pigues is at the justice department
jeff good morning
anthony those secret subpoenas didn't
just target journalists and democrats
but according to the new york times they
also targeted the electronic devices of
former white house counsel don mcgann
and now lawmakers here in washington
they're demanding answers the notion
that any president
via political appointees could
manipulate our democratic system to tap
into personal data has the fingerprints
of a dictatorship a dictatorship
all over it lawmakers on capitol hill
clashed over investigations into the
trump justice department's secret
subpoenas of members of congress
and the media there's no need for a
partisan circus
here in the congress in a statement
announcing the house judiciary committee
investigation monday
chairman gerald nadler alleged that the
department of justice used criminal
investigations
as a pretext to spy on president trump's
perceived political enemies
federal prosecutors secretly subpoenaed
phone information
dating back to 2017 and 2018 from apple
for congressional democrats eric
swalwell
adam schiff staffers and family members
including a minor
reporter's records were also subpoenaed
in connection with leak investigations
this is about the flow of information of
the public on monday
media executives met with attorney
general merrick garland to address the
growing controversy which started
under his predecessors former attorneys
general jeff sessions and william barr
have denied knowing about the subpoenas
former doj
acting assistant attorney general for
national security
mary mccord says that would be unusual
i would say this is something that would
have had to
go all the way up the flagpole to the
highest levels of the department for
approval
meanwhile john murrs who is the trump
appointee who led the national security
division through the end of the last
administration
has decided to leave the department of
justice this decision were made
we're told was made before these secret
subpoenas were made public
anthony jeff the house oversight
committee just released documents which
it says
show that former president trump tried
to use the doj to push
false election claims what can you tell
us about those documents
yeah these documents allege that last
december then
former president trump or former
president trump at that time sent an
email or had an assistant send an email
to then
deputy attorney general jeffrey rosen
that email
contained we're told false election
claims
in the state of michigan we're also told
that
less than an hour later president trump
then tweeted out that william barr who
was
then the attorney general would be
stepping down and that
mr rosen would be taking over as acting
attorney general at the department of
justice it was of course william barr
who said publicly that there was no
widespread election fraud anthony jeff
begaze thank you jeff